according to a report conor mcgregor
double this network with his recent
proper 12
irish whiskey sale was announced earlier
this week that mexican beverage
company besley exercised a call option
to acquire 51 percent
uh stake in ireborn spirits
the name behind proper number 12 irish
whiskey the sale was reported 122
million pounds uh which is roughly 155
million u.s dollars and effectively
pushed conor's net worth to over 300
million
by the way question yep good timing on
the sale great timing on the sale
exactly because
he is starting to decline
i mean the moment you start losing as a
fighter you you start losing your
platform you don't have a platform or
your platform is not as strong
then your whatever endorsements or
brands michael jordan said in the last
dance documentary
he said the greatest endorsement that i
could ever draw on in order to build was
what i did in the court
right if that starts to decrease in
performance then your
endorsements and your other
opportunities start to decrease too as
well
my opinion yeah i mean you i'm just
gonna i'm gonna double back
uh a month ago whenever that fight was
versus i couldn't even tell you
the guy he lost to his name at this
point what was his name
that's my point 48 48. okay cool yeah
in no in no way shape or form was that
guy a superstar
megastar he had he shouldn't have been
conor should have won that fight and
conor and khabib should have been going
at it right
how heated were you when conor lost you
were like i was
furious and not even because you're a
conor fan because you want to see
competition at the highest level you
want to who doesn't want to see him
fight exactly and you were like so
like you were like all right everybody
get the hell out of my house i am like
i'm done with this freaking fight we've
stayed we've watched every freaking
fight the girls fighting
the the you know the lightweights this
that we stayed up all night
ready to watch this fight at fricken
midnight connor that's right east coast
you have to stay up till midnight
yeah connor goes out there and he's
catching the guy's leg and he's catching
the guys he's kicking him he's kicking
him
boom gets knocked out and you were
so freaking pissed because you knew the
potential
of what was down the line the world
wanted exactly yeah
so when you remember what i said do you
remember what i said i said he doesn't
realize what he just did
yeah we almost need to show that clip
when we make this short clip and combine
that mario
have the editor put that part on what
was said about conor because we talked
about it and won the podcast
you know what i said what'd you say i
said he doesn't realize
proper 12's valuation just went down
yeah wow
100 and this is why you to zabala's
credit
timing is huge here because you lose one
more fight you lose your next fight
that might be another 100 million
dollars you lose by the way here's a
question for you here's a question for
you let me ask you crazy question right
now
you ready what did he sell it for 155
million dollars yeah what's his net
worth 300 million dollars right
i got a crazy question for you say he
beats 48 boom yep
does he sell today nope hell no watch
this
he beats portier dana white comes back
saying i just had a call with
khabib yep fight is set up cinco de mayo
yep
okay because he's calling out all the
boxers because
he says cinco de mayo khabib
against whatever you know connor and
say it's not even cinco de mayo he picks
a different time but it's going to be in
russia but it's going to be in different
place he calls the fight
okay and connor
beats khabib what's proper 12 worth
what's proper 12 words double triple
what it is whatever he says i think it's
bigger than that
it's really good i think it's bigger
than that well especially if he sponsors
the fight
sale wow i think it's a billion dollar
sale i think it's the difference between
him being worth 300 million and him
being worth a billion
wow i think that's how that's how much
that lost cost yeah this is going back
to what you said earlier
last night yeah two more years yeah
exactly come on
two more two more fights two more in in
their world right two more fights
two more fights two more fights so just
keep going it's crazy yesterday we're
sitting i'm like you know what's the
difference between all these guys that
are living in 10 20 million dollar homes
and the guys that are living in one or
two he says what's that
i said they convinced themselves to go
say two more years
five more times i don't know if that
makes sense or not which is like
i'm gonna go tee it up for two more
years and talk tomorrow
you go two more years two more years
later you're killing it we're like ooh
what if i go two more years oh my gosh
i've got
two more years and you go two more years
like oh i never thought i'd be at this
point right now business sports whatever
oh dude i don't know it's december 28th
and it's business planning time i'm
gonna go what if
i'm gonna go you know what two more
years conor needed two more big fights
he would have been a billionaire
he was two fights away from being a
billionaire he beats portier
he beats khabib he's a billionaire now
he's worth 300 million don't get me
wrong he's still got a great life okay
yeah
but but he would have been a guy from
having welfare in
you know what he was doing to you know
ridiculous motivation for the world
would have done
he would have been a billionaire funding
whatever the hell he wants to do
what because he's also a very smart guy
people don't realize conor is
a genius strategist marketer conor is
brilliant
i don't know what the guy's iq is on in
by the books
but the guy's iq in the streets is is at
the highest level yeah
and in this part it was taking the eye
off the ball a little bit
cost the guy 700 million bucks when you
said two more years two more years you
know
first person that comes to mind what's
that exactly i was about to say that i'm
just like thomas
the guy's gonna be 45 years old two more
years you keep saying two more years two
more years i just want a freaking super
bowl i'm gonna retire now
let's go get it again can you imagine
the guy wins the super bowl
breeze retires the conversation is
officially
you're not it's not even a conversation
right so this guy keeps going
keeps going keeps going he keeps staying
to two years two years two years
he tires everybody else out the the
conversation about who's the goat dude
it's so
overwhelming that people are like
separation forgettable
he's officially earned the right to say
by the way his argument is bigger than
jordan's argument
right let me explain the separation with
brady is a lot further than jordan's
and i'm a jordan guy but the separation
with brady's argument is
far ahead of jordan's argument why
because if jordan would have gone two
more years he would have eight
mm-hmm and if he wouldn't take those two
years he would have gone two more years
and he would if he would have been
that's ten yeah jordan's got ten no
one's saying lebron kobe wield kareem
nothing it's
over he would have 42 000 career points
he would have been a you know just
ridiculous statistics
so the two year two more your concept is
uh
and it's tough because man you worth 150
300 million dollars you're living in a
sick house you're having caviar every
night you're
eating lobster as if it's freaking you
know rice
and you're you got the cars everyone's
like hey oh my gosh no nothing got our
restaurant we don't charge you anything
how do you get up at that point and
drive it and do all this how do you do
that
the last 10 minutes of the last episode
of the last dance documentary of him
talking about
you know we we didn't even try to come
back as a team we didn't mean to try
team got explode but doesn't mean he
couldn't have rebuilt it or done
something else again
but the look of regret in jordan's eyes
it was an eerie look yep
there's something to be said about
longevity and sticking it out because
there you know
five seven years ago there was a debate
who was better peyton manning or tom
brady
and at the time yeah a lot of people
would have said peyton manning back
at the time or at least back and forth
now
the mannings of the world the breezes of
the world the merinos of the world the
montanas they're not even in the debate
anymore
longevity so and he's continuing to
extend the problem
by the way he is creating a lot of
enemies
because people are like retire already
i have to sleep next to my wife and
you know she'd bring up your name yeah
like hey did you see babe
what do you think you think he's gonna
win one more and you're like i don't
know babe i think it's not good to be
that narcissistic
so what do you tell your wife like
you're late next what do you actually
say to kind of give yourself power do
you say
you know honestly you think he's happy
you think he's sad because to me
marriage is more important
i love you more babe and wife's like
yeah i know you love me more but that
guy wants to get like from over
how about a six-year-old son innocent
son hey dad someone in school said
brady's better than you
i love you daddy but why did brady play
five more years more than you did
imagine you're like
get back to your room give me that ipad
throw the xbox in the trash that's tough
you know the one guy that can say i'm
better than brady
there's only one guy here we go
eli manning twice eli toretta go ahead
ryan leave eli manning he beat
brady twice in the super bowl well you
know
brady he blames everything on the the
mom
what mom eli and payton's mom if it
wasn't for eli payton's mom he would
have five more super bowls
he says that all the time oh yeah if it
wasn't for the mom he would have five
more super bowls because she gave birth
to these kids
yeah so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
you